now we'd like to do a quick icebreaker
so that you can meet the people around
you you've probably already met during
our long break before this but our
speaker came up with tonight's
icebreaker which is what is your
favorite Star Wars Star Trek or
Battlestar Galactica so take a few
minutes and let's come up with an answer
all right so can we get a show of hands
who went for Star Wars
what about Star Trek what about
Battlestar Galactica okay so we've got
supporters for all of them awesome
okay this month in data science I wanted
to make you aware that there's a Pike on
Canada event happening it's November
16th to 17th in Toronto and the deadline
for the call for proposals is at the end
of this month August 31st and there is a
PI data track that you can submit papers
to also make you aware of next month
speaker Kati Bauer
will be speaking on building time
on-site at read it and that will be
Wednesday September 11th here again at 6
o'clock now we have some time for
community announcements so if anyone has
anything they want to share with the
group if you have if you're looking for
talent or if you're looking for a job
now's your time to stand up and share
with the group good great
one more few more
I'm sorry I'm looking for like mid tier
data science talent for someone who
wants to work oh very cool
right here I'm Edward I work at a
research lab at the University of
Michigan and we're hiring kind of
interest level data scientists to work
with medical imaging data as well as
automotive data so Wow neat in the back
yep yep
possibly with Python
I have a background in finish processing
and Pettifer
15 pens in the area panda she wouldn't
face money
my background is
I applied math
and involved
code of development of
anyway I'm trying to move
career
great and what's your name Peter sit
great anymore Sean all right number one
there is a pi day to new york conference
coming up I think that's November 4th to
6th the call for proposals is ends and
August 31st to submit something there if
you're interested in giving a talk I've
been there for the past two years it's
great event a great location right in
the heart of a Times Square in New York
second thing I'd like to thank Patricia
for being our great host for the past
year so let's give her a round of
applause yeah tonight's my night my last
night with my dad a annarbor moving to
Oregon for a job at Intel so this was
great
I've loved it here I hope we all stay in
touch any other community organizations
Dan
like things and automotive these sports
analytics I'm looking for the next game
but most of long-term fast crate
homework I did a master's in math PhD
computer science and I'm a postdoc at
the University of Michigan right now for
making machine learning with data and
recently decided to start looking at
industry
excellent well thanks again for everyone
sharing and I hope you can all connect
after the night is over all right so I'm
gonna pass this off now to Clayton who
will introduce our speaker before I do
that I'm also hiring I work at ever
active and we do time series and sensor
data from Internet of Things sensors so
I'm looking for data scientist so if
that sounds like something of interest
find me after all this so a huge thanks
to Patricia Shawn rose and Ben for oh
can you hear me thank you
a huge thanks to pi data for allowing
this our group to co-host this Meetup
not only am i a Corgan Iser of the our
meetup but so is joe song andrew and
ellis over there and so yeah big thanks
to them for for putting this all
together for us even more excited to
announce or to introduce Jacqueline
Dulles our speaker tonight she's a
principal data scientist at nullus LLC
and you might know her from her very
popular Twitter sky tetra she is also
writing a book which I suspect you'll
hear a little bit about tonight she was
the winner of season three of the
reality show king of the Nerds and I'm a
particularly big fan of her because of
her less than safe for work articles on
things like analyzing sex survey data
and doing deep learning to generate
offensive license plates so I definitely
suggest it definitely suggest going and
digging up those and she also gave a
very good talk at the last our studio
conference which was in January on doing
API development with our and tensorflow
is one of the best talks there for
certain so thank you very much and thank
you
you know it's really funny about that
not-safe-for-work analyses because you
really want to go to conferences and
talk about them but like that code of
conduct said no sexual material and
conference talks and you got to balance
that that's a tricky game to play so
anyway so hi I'm Jacqueline olace and
I'm here today to talk about when data
science projects fail so a little bit
about me we kind of covered it already
but I'm gonna date a scientist for over
ten years
I'm currently I co-founded a data
science consulting company with my wife
which is what I do now before that I was
director of analytics at a consulting
firm called Linate before that I was the
lead of an aniline analytics at a
consulting firm called promontory that
did Bank consulting I have a PhD in
industrial engineering I won a reality
TV show and for fun I like making funny
data science models on the right here
you'll see just a couple of the
companies I've worked with t-mobile
Expedia Microsoft Airbnb so there's a
lot going on here that I can talk about
about me but I put that in quotes
because like what's that actually about
me um you know that's that slide it
really sounded prestigious but like if
you looked at that slide you'd be like
wow that person they haven't had any
difficulties ever right look at all
their successes right you know people I
think talk about especially in the data
science community we have a tendency to
talk a lot about our successes here's
the cool products I've done here's the
cool rolls I've had here's the TV shows
I've been on maybe that one's a little
less common but you know we talk about a
lot of out of our successes and we don't
really talk about our failures and you
know talking about failure is hard it
makes you feel vulnerable you have to
show weakness and so like I kind of get
it but I think this is a real problem
with data science as a community and so
well what is even a failure well it's to
me and you could have find this a bunch
of ways but when I think about a data
science failure I think you know it's
when you set out to do a data science
task but you are unable to complete it
and that could be something like hey you
can't even find the data in the first
place if your charm model relies on
getting historic order data maybe that
data isn't saved by your company maybe
you can't get you maybe you get the data
but then your model doesn't actually end
up fitting you know your r-squared is
point two or whatever and you're like
this can't actually be used
or maybe you make the model it works the
data is sufficient you you have this
model and for whatever reason the
stakeholders don't and abusing it and so
sure you've technically completed your
task as a data scientist of building a
model but if it never gets used then
that's not really a success because
success means that your work you know
data science job isn't to just build
models for fun they have to actually be
used so projects can fail in a lot of
different ways and failing is the worst
it's the worst why well first up it
hurts right because you work on a task
for so long and hopefully this lake
isn't triggering people in the audience
like yeah this has hurt me in the past
but you know these hurt right like you
think about these projects you worked on
so long and you've tried so hard to
succeed at them you haven't and so it
makes you feel inside like hey maybe you
know maybe there's something wrong it's
embarrassing right if you have to talk
to you know your boss other people about
hey this thing I set out to do I
couldn't do it's very easy to make that
feel like a sign of weakness and so
that's scary and also it ends your fun
projects if you're doing the super cool
natural language processing thing for a
year and well it's still not quite
working yet you know it's really fun to
just add a whole nother year on and keep
on working on it cuz it's fun you know
even if that doesn't mean that your
projects you know actually gonna succeed
so failing is not great but it's
important that we learn from our
failures and you know when I was a
junior employee this happened all the
time and when I'm a senior employee this
happens all the time which is my brain
tells me you know man if I was only a
better data scientist then I wouldn't
have failed at this right if I was a
better data scientist if I just knew
that one more technique that I haven't
read yet then the project wouldn't have
failed the model would have converged
the data would have been good enough and
so in my head I just would always during
my career have this notion of just the
more you know if I was only better if I
was only something else then the project
would have been okay but you know these
failures talking about these failures
even if that's true they can give us
great insight into what can go wrong you
know as we talk about our failures we
can understand what are the things we
should look out for the next time what
can we learn from it but to do that it
requires vulnerability we have to be
comfortable with our emotions about
failure and understanding the hurt you
know it requires vulnerability and a
career
sense right if you're a junior employee
you don't want to go to a conference and
have your first talk about how you
didn't succeed at something right like
there's a real career risk there and so
you know it's hard as a junior employee
it's less hard as a senior employee but
like for me even making this
presentation was kind of scary because
I'm gonna talk about some of my failures
and like I don't know maybe you guys
would have hired me as a consultant and
won't write like I know these thoughts
going through my head and it's
terrifying but at the end of the day
these failures happen everywhere all the
time in data science I highly suspect
that like 90% of the people in the room
can like think right now of a product
you worked on that did not succeed so
they're really out there all the time so
this is just something that we have to
deal with so i am i spent a assigns for
years i've been thinking a lot about
products failing and eventually I'm like
you know what I felt a lot I'm gonna do
what you do when you have a lot of
emotions and it's write a blog post so I
wrote a blog post at one point and I'm
like I'm gonna take all my feelings of
failure and I'm gonna put him out in the
blog post and I wrote this blog post I
think was like a year ago yeah a year
ago and and I just talked about you know
what are some of the ways projects can
can fail how can you handle that and I
write a fair amount of blog post this
one is one of my best KP I'd blog posts
ever it seems like a lot of data science
click on it so you know this is probably
not just something I have to deal with
so confession for the PI data people I'm
an art user primarily and so in the our
community the best possible thing that
can happen to you on Twitter
is that a guy named Hadley Wickham
retweets your article and so that
happened to me is I'm like yes I made it
I'm not a failure but there's a twist
and I look back on this piece and this
blog post now a year later and
throughout the blog post I barely
mentioned the failures I actually had so
in the blog post I talked about all the
ways you can fail all the things you
should look out for to try and succeed
but I never talked about my own failures
so I don't even do the thing I talked
about in a couple slides ago about
actually showing the emotional
vulnerability and talking about where we
have failed and so today I'd like to
rectify that for the next few minutes
we're gonna go through my top five
failures and why are we gonna do that
well it's important to learn from
mistakes right I think that by going
through some of the projects that I've
done during my career that have been
failures we can all kind of maybe
understand a little bit
why these projects can fail another
reason is you know it shows another side
of me it shows that I'm not just a
person who always succeeds at everything
I fail a lot all the time and it's
important that junior data scientist
understand that senior data scientists
do this too
it's not just something you happens
early in a career and lastly of my hope
is that if I'm more comfortable talking
about my failures then you all might be
more comfortable talking about your
failures too and you may be able to talk
to other people going forward about some
of the places that you weren't able to
succeed at what you set out to do so
with that let's do it let's show let's
go through my top five failures so
number one here we go the Adler Alert I
really like this one okay so this is me
I'm a month into a new job very early in
my career don't know very much about how
industry works month in this new job I'm
working at an e-commerce company and
this is a company that's primarily
powered by a website and on this website
like a month before I joined the company
they had a bug and normally when your
company has a bug on their website you
notice because you get like Arab reports
and devs DevOps sees things and that's
how you notice but what happened was
this company noticed the bugs because
the people in marketing saw that sales
were lower than they expected and then
they called up the software engineers
and said figure out what's going on and
then days later they fixed it and lost
millions of dollars and the people in
marketing were not happy right because
if you're in marketing you do not want
your job to be noticed problems with the
website that's bad and so one of the
executives from the marketing department
came to my organization specifically it
trickled down to me with like hey I'm
executives company this bug happened on
a Tuesday
send me the last eight Tuesday's worth
of sales I want to see how this Tuesday
compared to other ones so we can notice
if there's a problem and so I realized
that this executive was trying to do
some sort of like single analysis thing
of like how can you tell when there's a
problem but to me the executive was
setting out all wrong right you don't
want to just look at eight Tuesday's
well you really want to do is you think
much for thoughtfully of all the
different ways that you can try and
predict what should happen today right
so each day sales were growing a little
bit over and over because the company
was growing there's also holiday season
ality right so if you're in a Christmas
season it might behave differently than
if you are in other parts of the year
there's like a hundred of these little
tiny things that should really go into
affecting of well if we're at
$900,000 in sales today is that low
enough that we should have maybe a check
if there's a bug on there and so you
don't want to just look at like eight
Tuesday's you want to hold build a whole
tool to this to do this and so I'm like
really only my career I'm like I'm just
going to build something to do it and so
what I did was I took some statistical
quality control techniques and some time
series analysis techniques and I put
them together to create a signal
detection or an anomaly detection
service and executives saw this they're
like this is great they bought in they
got a team of people to work on it and I
was leading them and ultimately so my
maiden name was Adler and so early on my
career I didn't know and what you don't
have happen he's got a product named
after you but this product got named
after me this is terrible it's probable
for two reasons
one makes it look super arrogant which
is bad too
what's worse is that every time
something goes wrong with it they know
who to call and it's you so that
happened to me and so normally when I
talk about this project and
presentations like this this is where I
stop and we laugh and we think oh wow
Jacqueline did a cool thing and let a
team early in the career it's all cool
and so it seems like a great success but
actually this project was up failure and
the reason why was we built this tool
that was a time series an anomaly
detection service but what happened was
we then said okay instead of just
looking at sales over time let's also
look at you know orders revenue average
order value conversion rates and let's
do it not just for one region of the
company but for all the different
regions and so pretty soon we're trying
to predict 20 different KPIs and you
know if you have 20 KPIs and you have
95% confidence that means every day one
of them should be sending off an alert
which is really bad and then so and so
then even if you're single service is
really good and ours is okay you still
have problems and then I'm like okay I'm
early my career at the UI I'm gonna
decide to make coz you eyes aren't
important you don't need to worry about
that the hard part's the model was I'm
gonna make an Excel spreadsheet that has
a color where one is colored green and
has a high color and red is is is zero
and that's bad and you get this sheet
that has each row is a day and then you
just look at what today's data is and
you try to figure out what's going on
and the problem is that is impossible to
figure out what's going on right like is
is a red a problem sure is an orange a
problem it's a light orange a problem
right
there's no way to interpret this quickly
if you're a business executive and so
this UI was incomprehensible and it's
just we tried to do too many things that
went to this tool and then ultimately
this project got scrapped so we didn't
end up using it so despite the cool
techniques the Coulomb bottle real time
whatever it didn't work and it wasn't
used and that taught me something very
early in my career which is projects can
fail when the work isn't implemented
well so even if the work is done really
well when it comes time to implement it
to create the UI for it to create the
API whatever that can kill it and so
it's really important as data scientists
that we don't just get really stuck on
the models and the data but we think
really heavily about what's gonna happen
after that because that can really cause
a project to fail ok that's failure
number one let's keep going so number
two a full customer analysis so pretty
early in my career I switched from
working in industry to consulting and I
was doing some consulting for a retail
company and this company they had years
of data orders sales customer calls
whatever they just years great data they
had in store surveys they had data on
which emails customers clicked and what
they bought after that they had great
data but what they never had was a data
scientist at their company and so I was
there consulting as a data scientist
very excited and they said hey you know
we read all these articles about how
great data science is and how important
is a data is new oil whatever whatever
can you do some data science on this
data and find what's useful for us as I
said yeah sure I that is what I do I
find relationships and things and so I
took that data I joined the data
together and I found all these different
connections between different parts of
these different data sets and that's the
jacqueline's of success part and now
let's let's go to the twist this is an
embarrassing failure and why was that
because I did all this work and I walked
into this room full of executives at
this retail company and I show them a
bunch of stuff that was really useless
to them some of the things I found were
like hey customer this type of
high-value customer X buys this type of
product Y and they're like yeah we know
we walk around the store and we see them
do that every day like that does it help
us I don't be like okay okay here's how
about this lots of your customers like
really only 20% of your customers come
back
second time and they're like yeah we
know that too we see like we see people
not come back what can we do to fix that
problem and I'm like like I don't work
at retail I don't know
and so I'd write and so like this is the
kind of stuff I would do where I'd have
a chart that shows on the bottom one to
ten what was your likelihood to
recommend the company
so like Net Promoter Score stylist thing
and this would be the probability that
in when you were surveyed in store you
said the service was good and it's like
look at that relationship and it's like
yeah oh my god if you say this you're
gonna recommend the company you also
probably think the service is good right
like and so this is incredibly
embarrassing for me that I put all this
data science work into a project and
then I walked into a room of people and
it just totally fell flat and so the
lesson I learned here is that projects
can fail without a clear objective so I
don't think that data science was wrong
I don't think the report was wrong I
think the problem was that I walked into
that walked in on that first day
starting to do data science without
actually having a clear objective except
fine things and I think it's very easy
as data scientist to want to do this
right you get a new data set it's
interesting you want to find the the
hidden signals in there but if you don't
actually have a clear objective of what
you're gonna do with it it's very
unlikely you will just happen to find
something that is so interesting it will
alter the business so it really helps as
much as possible when you start a data
science project to have that clear
objective number three ah I don't know I
keep like smiling when I see the new
ones I think of all that trauma so here
we go so I was working I was consulting
for a large company and this company
they were releasing lots of applications
right mega-corporation very large to
have all sorts of applications they set
out and one of the things they did being
a smart company is before they release
the new version of an app they had
humans test that so they ended up having
like a floor of a building just fill the
people like testing apps and making sure
that every part of the apt worked right
and specifically what they did was they
had a list of tests right they have like
100 200 some number of tests and they
have to go through each test and make
sure yes the app passed this test
yep the odd pets passed this test but
also these apps create a lot of Salama
tree so every time you do something in
the app like press a button it would
actually send that data to
server that you press that button and so
you might have an app telemetry with
things like Oh at this time the app
started and then this button was clicked
and then it actually successfully
connected to the server and thrown out
and you have like giant giant logs with
this and so the idea was what if we used
the telemetry created from the app to
tell if it would pass the tests or not
right so if you could if there was a
test in here that was the app
successfully starts and stops and you
saw him to telemetry the app start and
app stopped telemetry actions and events
then you might not need to have a human
actually manually checked out yourself
and so this project was a work from a
combination of the Quality Assurance
team so the people who manage those that
floor full of people and the tests and
the data science team which I was a
member of or the you know the people who
come in and try and automate some the
best so these two teams are gonna work
together and try and automate this
Quality Assurance so I got brought into
the project part of the way through it
and me when I saw three days in I'm like
oh my god this project will not succeed
and it was like you know maybe part of
that was just shock of getting in the
middle of it and maybe if I've been at
the storm I've been different but I was
really discouraged and the reason why
was you know as a data scientist it's
really important to not just look at
data and so the one of the first things
I did was actually spent hours poring
through each one of those like 200 tests
and all the different definitions of it
in requirements and most of the tests
ended up being things like there were
correct grammars in the apps menu right
so like the apps actually like when you
clicked on a menu the grammar in there
was good and if you think about
telemetry app start apps top things like
that there's almost no way it would
include what words were in the menu and
even if it did getting a
machine-learning bottle to actually tell
if that grammar was good is itself a
hard problem too and so of those hilum
terabytes of telemetry from the apps
little bit actually related to the tests
that were involved most of them were
things like is the processor on the
computer at the right temperature things
like that so only a few of the tests
could be plausibly automated like for
instance you could imagine there's a
test like there exists telemetry for
this app and like okay short maybe that
one could be automated probably but even
when we did the models that we created
for these they often had an intolerable
accuracy right so if you're talking
about an app being released to the
public
you want to be
positive it passes all these tests and
if you're a machine learning model that
reads the telemetry can only be like 80%
accurate or like only agree with what a
human would say 80% of the time that's
probably not sufficient for this to
actually succeed as a project and these
things could all be told very early on
into the project right you don't need to
spend months and months and months
before you notice all of these things
but the probably project did go for
months and months and it went on for
over an year ended up being a prisoner's
dilemma a Nash equilibrium if you will
and so there were two teams there's a
Quality Assurance team and the data
science team and if you're if you have
two teams and one says this isn't gonna
work the other team gets to say why
aren't you a team player of course it's
gonna work you just need to stick with
it and that team looks good and the
naysayer team looks bad
and so what ends up happening is neither
team wants to be the naysayers they both
want to be the of course this will work
if we just try a little harder and so
what ends up happening is you get this
Nash equilibrium where you're just
continuing on this project over and over
even though everyone knows it's not
going to work and that's not really
great and so I learned that this data
science project I would say it failed
ultimately because of poor leadership
right people could have quickly decided
this product should've been scrapped but
it wasn't and went on and on on and
that's a real failure but you could also
say the project failed because the
single was hard at attacking the noise
right you couldn't find the you couldn't
make a model that could accurately
predict the test based on those
terabytes of data there really just
wasn't a single there and that's bad
okay number four so this is a project I
did in my personal time so back when the
website Kickstarter is a website where
you can go to and there are these
campaigns where people come up with a
like an idea for a product and people
pledge money to it and I'm not people
pledge money to it the product the gets
launched and everyone gets a copy of it
like a board game or a water bottle and
it's a very popular website and what
happens is the campaign needs to hit a
certain threshold to succeed and so
someone made a different website that
would actually analyze data from the
Kickstarter website and tell you part of
the way through a campaign if that
project is going to succeed so if our
water bottles need $50,000 to succeed
and we're ten days in and we've sold
we've
earned $10,000 on those water bottles do
we think that projects imma succeed or
not and so what that Walternate website
did to do the predictions was actually
fairly simple it was something like well
if it's been 10 days and we've earned
$10,000 and there's 20 days left let's
assume we will earn $20,000 on that day
on those days and then sum that all up
and say well we'll earn $30,000 total
and not have that project succeed so
it's basically assuming a constant
amount of revenue each day and so when I
thought about this I'm like well there's
two things we probably can assume one is
that actually when the project is
launched everyone gets excited about it
it goes viral hey cool a new water
bottles for sale and so there's probably
a big bump at the beginning of the
campaign and similarly near the end oh
we're only one day left from being close
and we need $50,000 to get these water
bottles and we're at 48,000 so everyone
put in extra money like you could
imagine there's a boost at the end - so
I assuming like I figure there's
probably two humps in this and so I said
hey so I emailed this person out of the
blue I said hey love your website hey
I'm a data scientist love making data
analyses and forecasts can I try and
take your data and analyze it to see if
I can do better and I could not so I
spent weeks on this and what ended up
happening was my model had this
assumptions that there's a hump at the
beginning in the end but it turns out
that's often not true sometimes some
project only had the hump at the end
some only have at the beginning some
have one in the middle when a news
article went out and so my model was
really having difficulty with these and
what I would do is that add-on feature
after feature okay what if we make a
feature that's the first ten days at the
forecast what if it's the last one what
and so I made this model more and more
complicated and eventually after the
model got sufficiently complicated I did
in aggregate I would do slightly better
than that flat line role but I'd only
barely beat that basic rule and it was
immensely complicated you couldn't
really explain how it worked because
it's super complicated it you know it
just oftentimes it still did worse on
particular cases and I did it in R and
so like to deploy it you'd have to have
like are installed in the server and I
didn't at the time know anything about
making api's and so it was this
complicated mess and I basically emailed
the person back and be like look piers
but I did hahaha and I never got in
reply to Pat I probably wouldn't have
replied either so I get us but it was
really disappointing to me because I
really
that out in thoughts I think I'm a data
scientist this is a very clear data set
I can make a great model and things will
go great and it did not and so the
lesson I learned here is be prepared for
your models to not be accurate right no
matter how clear you think the data set
might be you never know when it's
actually data set that's not very it
doesn't have a single in there and this
is probably of all the projects in this
this is the one that haunts me the most
of like you know I still look at this
presentation and be like well maybe I
should open up that data set one more
time now that I know new techniques and
see if I can do again but like that's
not a good idea like you got to move on
from stuff and I think I need to just
let go that like at that you know really
I just wasn't able to succeed at that
one even though it seems like it was
fairly straightforward and that's okay
okay last a retail customer simulation
so retail companies like Nordstrom's
Sears Macy's whatever often they have
trouble understanding the effects of
coupons discounts or rewards so if
you're a company you're Nordstrom you
want to put out a coupon $20 off your
next purchase it's really hard to figure
out how valuable that's gonna be right
because you don't know well if I give
people that coupon how many more people
will come in because that coupon and if
they come in how much more spending
would they have made had they not have a
coupon and there's all these weird
interrelated effects because if you
actually just look at historic sales
when you have like previous coupons you
never know if the people who came in to
use the coupons for your best selling
customers who would have bought more
anyway and so it's just like it's a real
thing to untangle to try and find the
value of these different programs and so
typically what happens is it's
financially models in Excel so what what
business people will do is it'll make an
Excel spreadsheet and they'll say okay
we think we're gonna we're gonna give
out fifty thousand coupons we think
10,000 of those coupons will actually be
used for each coupon we're gonna assume
people spend $50 more for purchase and
they do these multiplications until they
get what they think is the value of the
coupon giving it up but I as a
consultant doing data science was like
we sure they can do better and what I
thought about is what if we did a
simulation right so for each customer
let's actually simulate the orders they
make next so if I have a customer let's
let's use some machine learning to try
and predict what's
next order gonna be and the one after
that one after that and how are all
these orders gonna change because of a
coupon and if I can do these simulations
for all customers and I can do it for
all customers and I can then aggregate
that up that should tell me the value of
the coupon and so I spent months
creating a tool to do this and what it
would do is it would actually have a
sequence of different machine learning
models and what you do is for each
customer you'd say okay I've just made
an order I'm gonna look and you sell
like let's say a regression to say what
is the amount of time it will take for
their next purchase and because I want
some randomness in there I won't just
take the exact optimal prediction from
the regression I'll add some noise to
that and I'll do the same thing for that
order size and a couple other factors
and from there I'll make a huge sequence
of orders and then I will just that for
what happens if there's a coupon on
there I'll say well the coupons gonna
make this order ten percent bigger which
is gonna make the next one ten percent
faster blah blah blah you do that for
the simulation for everyone and you roll
it all up and so I built this tool and
real companies paid real money to use it
which was like the coolest thing ever
for me at the time I'm like oh my god my
work really has value but there's a
twist so what what happened is after
every client used it they'd be like well
you know this is interesting and this
this poor guy seems good but we don't
really get why it's making it and you
know could you just could you just take
what you did and like put it in some
simple Excel formulas we can give to
finance and I was like I just spent
months trying to not do that oh my god
and so what I realized in those moments
was that really what these clients
didn't want what they did not want is a
prediction of ROI return on investment
they didn't want that they say the devil
the data what they really want is the
smallest amount of work necessary to
prove to finance that what they want to
do is a good idea right and so all you
need to do is prove that the company
will not get bankrupt by this coupon and
you have a success and so anything about
simulations you know big data
buh-buh-buh all that stuff is just
making it more difficult for finance to
accept it and so what would happen is
that we do all this like a client might
be interested in buy into the service by
using the model but we'd ultimately
still have to do the same financial
modeling as before and so this ended up
you know largely being a failure and I
think what I learned from this is make
sure you understand what a customer
needs you know it was very easy to be in
my kind of consulting
my chair and be like ah machine learning
is better accuracy is better we will do
that and what I should have recognized
very early on is the client was finance
finance really likes things they can
understand and you know how do I talk to
finance people a little bit more had I
done a little bit quicker of an MVP
instead of building this huge product I
probably would have more quickly
realized that this huge product was not
really a good idea um but it was really
fun so huh okay so those are my five
failures and you know I learned a lot
from them and I talked about some of the
lessons in each one but what are the
sort of themes that I got from putting
all these different failures together
so one lots of projects fail um so for
me I think it's like 75% of my projects
fail something like that some very high
number it's definitely more than half
and the reason why I think that is the
case is because data science like it's
not software engineering it's mostly
research and development right if you
have a machine learning model you're
asked to built on a new data set no
one's ever done that before and in a
sense you're researching is it even
possible to use this you know this order
data to predict if these customers will
churn right that's a research question
you are trying to get a research answer
so it's very you know it's very hard to
know that in advance without trying to
do stuff trying to do it yourself and so
in that way data science is like built
on the idea that you're gonna try stuff
and because you're trying all this new
stuff it often won't work and that's
okay that's part of the process I think
there are really three big types of data
science failures that I've dealt with
one there's not enough data deal with -
there's not a single and three it's not
right for the customer so not enough
relevant data and I didn't talk too much
about these in my top five failures but
I've had plenty of these - which is you
set out to do a project and it turns out
there's not even the data there for it
right like maybe you want to do that
churn model and it turns out you don't
actually have order data for the
relevant customers and you don't know
that until you actually started on the
project um this often happens because
it's not well collected like for
instance there are plenty places where
companies only keep records like you
know only keep people's current emails
but not what their email was previously
before they changed it or you know other
things like that were they don't keep
historic versions sometimes it's
impossible to collect right there's a
lot of analyses for retail companies
especially that be really well-suited if
you
knew what customers were spending at
other companies too right if you're
Macy's you want it like knowing how much
these customers also spent at Nordstrom
would be great but you can't get that
data and there's really no way you will
ever get that data and then the data
might be within your company but it
might be disjoint over many systems so
you know you may have the data but this
parts in one database and this parts in
another and this parts in another and
they all use different keys and these
people are kind of being mean about
giving you access to the data and so
while the data might exist it might be
so difficult to obtain that it's not
worth the amount of time it would take
to invest in getting it and so generally
the fixes are collecting new data if you
can possibly do that or finding
alternate data in your company but these
are tricky to pull off if there's not a
single in the data if like if there's
too much noise like you know in the case
of telemetry where there's so much stuff
that's basically garbage you can't
figure out what is interesting um or
sometimes it never existed and the case
I like to use is if you had a boss and
your boss says roll a 6-sided die 10,000
times and you do it you write down each
time what the die roll was in order and
then your boss says to you okay great
now build a machine learning model to
predict what the next roll of the die
will be no matter how good you are as a
data scientist you will not be able to
predict anything better than a 1/6
chance because there's no single in
there it never existed and I think that
happens a lot where we assume that oh
surely whether or not someone is going
to leave our company can be seen by what
orders they make but you never know
maybe people leave your company because
they're all moving to another state
I don't know right like there's lots of
cases where if things you suspect to be
inside the data aren't there and so this
can be fixed by finding maybe if you can
find better data sources you can fix it
but often what like often you start with
the best right you usually don't start
with the second best so again this is
tricky to pull off
and lastly things may not be right for
the customer so one it wasn't validated
so like my situation with that simulate
simulation tool I didn't really go
through and validate that this would be
something that was useful for the
customers another big problem is there's
no stakeholder so I think it's very
natural as a data science team to be
like you know it would be cool if we had
a churn model based on our orders that
would be really cool and so you build it
you have this cool churn model and then
you're like okay and then no one in the
company actually cares right they're
like we don't we can just predict we can
just predict whether or not a customer
is going to try
if I haven't purchased in 12 months and
it's fine we don't need it we don't get
it
and so it really is important to have as
much as possible have someone who is
interested in the product you're going
to make before you start not after it is
done and then lastly politics anyway
this is true at any company but
sometimes it's just your data science
team is competing with a data
engineering team or I don't know like
there's all these different things that
can go on and you know it's just like
the weather data scientists don't really
have that much control over it the best
thing in be situation you can do is try
and change the product to be a better
for the customer but again these are all
difficult things to make during a
project but it's important to make the
best of it so if you can think about for
each one like a project to fail like
what successes you can get out of it you
can help avoid problems in the future as
this tweet by de koning talked about how
on her team you know they actually did a
situation where they wrote down some of
the successes they got from a failed
project and they realized they actually
had quite a few and for me one of the
situations has happened was with that
Adler Alert with that that green and red
rug of ambiguity so that tool was
ultimately not useful but what was
useful was the original algorithm we
then tried to we then put into a simple
Excel tool so some marketing executives
could see each day how much they were
going to make and so that wasn't as
ambitious as the original project but
like we were able to salvage something
out of it and sometimes that can happen
on project you failed with also cutting
and running is great so failing projects
can have a drag on a team so that is to
say if you have a team of five data
scientists and two or three of them are
working on a project that is clearly not
going anywhere and there they need to
spend months months more before it maybe
go somewhere oftentimes the best thing
to do is just say no it isn't not worth
the time and that's because it's a huge
opportunity cost right every project
that a data scientist is working on that
is probably going to fail is that today
the scientists could be working on
something new and having more potential
and so it's very easy in this field to
have the sunk cost fallacy of like well
we put so much time into it let's just
put a little bit more but the quicker
and more comfortable you can get between
iterating through different ideas the
better and I think software development
like startups are really good at this
the idea of like pivoting and sales
fail often like I think that is kind of
important for data science to like don't
get stuck on one project cuz it seems
really cool for too long if it doesn't
seem like it's gonna pan out this was
supposed to animate that's okay okay so
so at the start of my career I really
believed that data scientists were like
carpentry or like building a house so
here you have a data scientist and
they're building a house and I guess
building a house has to do with cutting
wood I don't really know I've never
bought the house but but you build you
build a house and it's really important
if you're a carpenter building a house
that that house is sturdy and solid and
everyone depends on it and you meet the
specifications and then you're done with
it you move on that's like a house and
then a senior data scientist they're not
just building houses they're building
skyscrapers right they've done so many
years of this they know how to add
floors and elevators and features but
these are super stable very reliable if
a skyscraper fell over that person would
be fired and never have a job again and
so as a data scientist I thought your
job was to never let your building fall
over so every task you were assigned to
you were supposed to succeed at within
specification to move on so that's how I
thought the world worked at the start of
my career and here's what I think the
work world works like now so now I think
data scientists they're like treasure
hunters in a cave right and if you're a
junior data scientist treasure hunting
or I guess you know in an island because
there's a tree I guess you're you're you
have a simple map and you're trying to
navigate the small space but like you're
trying to look for something very hard
to find success and a senior data
scientist it's the same thing only with
a bigger map there's more dragons
there's whales more islands whatever but
at the end of the day if you are a
treasure hunter and you found treasure
twice you are a legendary treasure
hunter right treasure hunters are like
it's extremely hard to find treasure if
you set out to find treasure you don't
no one is surprised and so it's really
an exploratory thing and it's not like a
data scientist is um you know like a
senior data scientist is more likely to
succeed at finding treasure it's just
that they because they're senior they're
maybe gonna set out on the harder trying
to find the harder treasures but they
still not don't find treasure all the
time so actually finding treasure is
fantastic and we should be really
excited about that
and then lastly that thought I had at
the beginning if you are a better data
scientist you wouldn't have failed
I kind of realized this is um this
should be replaced with the idea of like
hey if you are failing as a data
scientist you probably aren't taking
enough risks if every one of your models
works and every one of your analysis is
a is a like lands perfectly that's
probably a sign that your analyses
aren't ambitious that your models are on
extremely clear data and so it's
important to embrace the idea I thought
like you you should be having failures
because otherwise you're not having big
enough successes you're not really going
out of your comfort zone and you know at
first I kind of thought of this as like
almost like impostor syndrome right like
impostor syndrome is the idea that like
oh I'm secretly like I'm actually a
terrible data scientist and no one
everyone's gonna realize it and
everyone's knows I'm secretly bad but
like I think very good people who are
very comfortable and how good they are
at Zeta scientists could have these sort
of thoughts too but really it's not
about whether or not you're good or bad
data scientists it's the idea that
you're the weakest link right the reason
why the project failed was you right
it's not the data it's not the models
because you didn't know enough things
and it's about this mental image that
you're the weakest link and everything's
relying on you and you are the thing
that snapped and fell apart and I think
that's really wrong now as I'm more
senior person and I think it's almost
like weirdly arrogant right like the
idea that like oh the project would have
succeed if it were not for me like no
like you can't control politics you
can't make data better you can't make
single in there the idea that you like
the idea that you're the thing that's
stopping all that like that it's not
right like you can't hold yourself to
that level of accountability it's
insanity
and so I realized I had a lot of this in
my career this weakest link syndrome
that like I had to be better and I was a
big problem and like one of the things
I've really tried to do as much as I can
as a senior data scientist who's like
just been around a little bit is just
really get comfortable the idea that
like projects fail for lots of reasons I
have to accept that and I can't blame
myself
for all of it so with that I encourage
you guys to all go forth be more
comfortable failing talking about
failing I'm really trying to work on
that myself and I have a few last slides
on this so one if you're like oh this is
great I really want to feel better and
maybe want to succeed really want to
feel better you can hire me I'm a data
science consultant I work for lots of
companies I do
data science AI and machine learning
consulting in particular I help
companies that are growing or starting
their data
team's defining data strategies or
building small improvement concepts to
validate if ideas are good or not and
you can go to that website and so yes
you can hire me also if you're like I
wish I knew more about navigating a data
science career then I have good news I
have a book coming out so me and Emily
Robinson who my understanding is gonna
be a speaker here in the upcoming months
we are co-authoring a book build your
career in data science that really goes
through the steps from how do you get
the skills to be a data scientist to
nailing an interview to building your
first analysis to becoming a manager so
you can buy it now you get the first
nine chapters and then as the rest of
the chapters come out you get them as
they immediately have to come out but
the full book will be available early in
2020 and you can get 40% off if you buy
it right now with the builds book 40 at
HDTV close hush-hush best book cool
it's very memorable and so with that
thank you so much
[Applause]
yeah okay so the question was hey it's
cool to go up and talk about how failure
it's great but like failure hurts other
people and teams and things like that
and how do you manage the fact that your
failure has consequences throughout the
organization so I think that's a great
question and I think it's very hard to
do because ultimately people are relying
on you to do something that you are
unable to do so the best thing you can
do about this is try and mitigate the
risks through communication right like
let people know very early on hey we're
trying to build this machine learning
model we need to do the exploratory
analysis to see if it's even feasible
and then after a few weeks if it seems
like it's feasible like you know we will
report back on that right like trying to
put as many steps along the way as you
can of like hey and then we're gonna
have a check here if we think it works
and then we're gonna have a check here
and so some of the biggest projects I've
been on that I've failed in ways that
really hurt the organization
we're ones where at the start like we
signed a giant contract we said and we
will build this model for you and it
will work right and what we should have
done and what we did in later contracts
was say okay we're gonna have a
two-month period where we're gonna do
the exploratory analysis and then we
will decide if we want to continue and
so the more you can kind of do these
steps of like hedging the risk the
easier it is so it's really coming back
to the idea that you don't want to be
overconfident and sell everything
upfront like be just very open at the
beginning but like hey this is
exploratory we're gonna try stuff it'll
hopefully work but if it doesn't like we
need to have a plan for that oh yeah
sure it was it was oh yeah yeah I think
I went too far
yeah for customer now so it was yeah the
time I went front of a presentation
really embarrassed myself sorry which
one oh yeah
[Applause]
yeah yeah right exactly and so this is
actually this is like the top one but
this is happened a number of times in my
career and it generally especially
happens with smaller companies so like
have it had data scientists before they
get really hyped up on the idea that
their data has value in it but like
that's not really how data work so it
really it's like you have an objective
you want to achieve and data can help
you with that right so like maybe it's
you want your customers to stick around
longer data can help you understand why
right you want to like you could have a
business objective but companies who
don't have data scientists before they
think that data can help them find the
objective right so like if you look at
the data data for long enough you will
notice some secret thing we didn't know
about and that will help us figure out
what we should change about our company
and every time the company has come to
me with that kind of work which
ultimately happened was for the most
part I did the thing that happened right
here which is I told them stuff they
already knew so if you don't have an
objective like what are you trying to
get out of data like what are the ideas
and hypotheses that you think that you
can validate or disprove with the data
or use the data to do then if you don't
have that you want the data come up with
it for you it like often doesn't work
yes exactly
yep exactly just analyze for the sake of
showing analysis is useful like does not
work very well yes
yes so great question and so the thing I
always suggest is you create an analysis
plan like the before you actually start
the analysis create a plan so say our
objective is to understand why customers
are leaving our analysis the first thing
we're to do is look at it by region in
each region we're gonna create a blah
blah blah right and just come up with a
list of steps and then when you do your
analysis you can go everyone can sign
off yeah these seem like a good idea
then when you go to your analysis you'll
be very clean and crisp on I'm doing
stuff that's useful for the problem
trying to solve instead of getting lost
in the weeds of like oh this seems like
it might be interesting someday and then
if it turns out that like you need to
adjust your plan on the fly that's fine
but having that like starting like one
page document of like here's everything
I want to do before I get started can
really lower the risks you have of like
coming in and then you'd automatically
hype like prove something you know yeah
you bias here I'm saying a lot of words
that don't make sense but are you going
and you you do something that's biased
or flawed can you discuss to be
mentioned some like sort of simple ways
that you can arrive you can sort of
determine that there's no signal there
before we're going and building like the
most complicated yeah that's a great
question there a great request so how do
you how can you tell before you invest
all the time in if there's gonna be a
signal or huh and so my general
philosophy is that anything a human can
be able to tell a machine learning model
will be able to tell and I think a human
can't tell machine learning model can't
so if a human can't look at like a whole
bunch of lines of telemetry to have any
idea what's going on a machine learning
model probably can't and if a human
can't look at ordering data and with
like look at a bunch of orders and try
and tell it like tell you oh this
customer's definitely gonna leave a
machine learning model probably can't so
step one is just have a human see if it
seems like a something Akeem akin to and
the other thing is I've it's rarely been
the case to me that a super complex deep
learning whatever model super complex
model works and a simple one doesn't
it's usually case that the simple one
works okay and the con book one works
better
and so what that means is that you
should start by trying the simple one
really fast and if that doesn't work
abort and if it does work then switch
today doing the complicated one and I
seen data scientists get hung up on this
a lot because you're really excited as a
data scientist yeah big data set the
first thing I wanna do is the super cool
neural nets blah blah blah and then it's
like well you spent two months doing
that and if you done a linear regression
you would have noticed that the
regression didn't work at all
so that prevent they probably want to
work either
that's a good question so how does the a
domain industry the industry and domain
knowledge affect the model creation so
that's a good question for me it's like
it usually doesn't create affect the
model creation as much it usually
affects much more the getting to the
point where I'm gonna create a model in
the first place right so like having
those conversations with the business
people understanding what their real
problems are understanding how data can
solve that part is where the business
knowledge is really useful and when you
finally get to the point where you like
you know what it is a good idea to take
order data and try and predict which
customers are gonna leave when you
finally get to that point it's not as
important to understand the details like
whether or not it's like airplane orders
or you know Nordstrom orders whatever
like it's usually still like a logistic
regression but the really hard part is
figuring out like hey does this setting
up the data in this way make sense at
all
or should we have not even tried but
that's not for me I've noticed like
that's really where the domain knowledge
has helped me out
going back to the retail clients who the
real client was can you is there
anything else you can say in terms of
your your perspective from the outside
of an organization yeah you know it's
really hard and as a consultant you can
eat very easily get burned by this by
signing on for a project and then like
oh well the client won't ever have data
because the people have data don't want
to work with you right so like those
sorts of things really happen and you
know I don't know if I have a good
answer to how to avoid those sorts of
situations to find who the real truth
holder is but I do know that it's like
at the end of the day it's all about
like negotiation and communication so
it's like it's like business book stuff
right like it's really like it's really
a matter of just trying to like be very
upfront with the client you're working
with and really understand hey do you
have this data if you don't you know
who's gonna be able to get it can I talk
to them right like we're they're just
trying to be very comfortable and no
understanding what the risks are upfront
being able to talk to the people
involved and then when you notice hey
those people would be really
uncomfortable being able to very quickly
go back to your first person and being
like hey let's have a conversation about
that so and this is the thing you know
fair number of people come up to me and
they'd be like hey I'm interested in
becoming an independent consultant too
and you know because I really just want
to make be the person who makes the
models and do all that and like to be
the independent consultant is to like
50% of your job is doing that kind of
stuff is doing the conversations
negotiation to figure out what's going
on and so I don't have an easy answer to
that but I do think it's one of those
things that you want to continue to do
and get practice at and just get better
and better because it's just a skill you
build up over time like other things
last night but also but also for showing
ulnar both side with us - thank you
thank you
thank you